afternoon everybody thank you so much
for coming to this
community practice Grand Rounds this is
a series offered out of the office of
the associate dean and theoretically CC
PG ours run the last Wednesday of every
month except when we have them on other
days and we do that sometimes to
accommodate schedules or or whatnot to
have some flexibility but today it is my
great pleasure to welcome to Columbia
University School of Social Work mr.
Jonathan Mintz who is the Commissioner
of the New York City Department of
Consumer Affairs and he's been so since
2006 during his tenure Commissioner
Mintz has been extremely productive and
tackled large-scale enforcement and
litigation work that's focused on ending
industry-wide deception practices in the
consumer marketplace and significantly
increase the volume of New Yorkers who
are protected and educated about their
finances such as debt collection and tax
preparation and he is leading the
nation's most comprehensive
comprehensive campaign to boost
awareness and uptake for the Earned
Income Tax Credit for our working
families and individuals Commissioner
Mintz has launched the department's
office of financial empowerment and this
office is the first local government
initiative in the nation aimed expressly
at educating empowering and protecting
those with low incomes so they can build
assets and make the most of the
financial resources that they have this
this initiative has been profiled in The
Economist the American Banker American
public media and it's a really unique
and important way of approaching poverty
reduction trying to increase financial
stability and asset building by
leveraging powers and opportunities of
the municipal government mr. Mintz has a
law degree from Cornell University and
he also holds a master's degree from
Bank Street and I thought very
interestingly in his biography is that
in addition to practicing medicine in
addition to being on the law faculty of
Roger Williams University he
also was a second-grade teacher at the
little red schoolhouse in Greenwich
Village
so welcome Commissioner myths I promise
I won't make you all sit on the carpet
and build with blocks or anything like
that although I love blocks it's very
nice of you your introduction is very
kind the awkward thing is I think we
wrote it and and the work that I get
credit for in the introduction is
actually done by the people who are here
so I have to give them give them their
due no I'm really thrilled to be here
and I appreciate you all taking time out
of your lunch time breaks to come here a
little bit about the work that we've
been doing and I think the very fact
that I have this opportunity to talk to
people like you underscores this
interesting new world that we've
embarked on over these last few years at
the Department of Consumer Affairs
trying to take a very new approach to
the way in which we use government to
help change people's lives in the sphere
of their finances so let me give you a
little bit of history of how we got
there and what I'm actually talking
about and I want to walk you through
sort of how the mayor and my team and I
have been thinking about this work and
growing it and pushing it out and the
role that Columbia is playing that's so
helpful and exciting and talk to you a
little bit about the class that's being
offered here there'll be a shameless
pitch directly following my remarks and
then maybe hopefully we get a little bit
of a chance to talk which is the part
that I'm looking forward to most
so DCA the Department of Consumer
Affairs is one of several city agencies
we are largely a regulatory agency our
mission revolves around ensuring a fair
market place for consumers so we do that
in a number of different ways we
regulate dozens of different
industries we enforce truth in
advertising regulations we have
inspectors and judges and lawyers and
communications people etc etc I'm told
by one of my deputy commissioners who's
here fran freedman who's an alum of this
school that our mission statement is a
social worker mission statement and that
that right right away should make you
love us it's that the Department of
Consumer Affairs empowers consumers and
businesses to ensure a fair and vibrant
marketplace apparently she snuck in
during our strategic planning session
the your social work your social work
ethic ethic so I think that's that's
exciting and of course it's very much
what we're about and as I say the
Department of Consumer Affairs is a
regulatory agency in the spectrum of
work done by the city to help people
fight poverty we didn't used to be part
of that mix it's not the way that when
you organize City Hall by its deputy
mayor's and this deputy mayor does
Health and Human Services and this
deputy mayor does Economic Development
and all of that we were always in the
economic development sort of economy
business part of the portfolio because
we were out there helping and hammering
businesses to get it right when they
treated their customers something very
interesting happened about seven years
ago when the mayor put together a
blue-ribbon panel to think about new
ways that the government could be smart
about fighting poverty and I'm sure you
all have been subjected to many reports
and panels and all of that where you
tend to hear some of the usual things
this panel had a bunch of really
exciting and innovative ideas I'm told I
wasn't a part of it again we were the
we're the enforcement folks down the
road but one of the things they said was
unbelievably tired and usual and
expected which was gee there ought to be
more financial education everyone says
it no one knows what they're talking
about when they say it but everyone
thinks it's a good idea and it's always
going to show up in people's
recommendations
about how to approach poverty but
interestingly the mayor and Linda Gibbs
who's the deputy mayor for Health and
Human Services when they were going
through the panel's recommendations
didn't just gloss over this
recommendation they said to themselves
oh yeah more financial education that's
a good idea you know Mayor Bloomberg's
background he's a great believer in
information and the role that it can
play in empowering people's lives and so
the question for them was well which
Commissioner do we call you know to beat
over the head and say you need to be
doing more financial education and it
occurred to them that nobody in local
government does financial education
that's not really what government does
government does direct services if
you're homeless we're going to find you
a shelter and try to get you assistance
if you're hungry we're going to be the
conduit to various public assistance
opportunities if you get in trouble we
will arrest you you know but just one of
our larger um but but the idea that
government is out there sitting down
with people and saying let's talk about
your finances let's figure out how to
clean up some of these messes let's
figure out how to start to build some
savings and all of that it's just not
what government does there's a thriving
nonprofit sector that I'm sure you're
all very well aware of that for decades
and decades have been approaching
financial education and asset building
and doing some really terrific work from
within their own spheres so I'm the one
that ended up with the late-night email
saying well you all have done this
outreach campaign for the EITC
which was really just sort of an
accidental piece of work that we were
doing some you know important work but
not really part of who we were and why
don't you think about what you all could
do to do more financial education the
other clear signal that I got from the
mayor was as always if you're going to
get additional resources if you're going
to be using existing resources it needs
to make a difference you need to be
doing something that makes a difference
and so we started asking ourselves well
what is unique value add on the part of
city government in this world that is so
traditionally completely occupied in the
nonprofit sector and we started thinking
a little bit not so much about financial
education but more and more thinking
about people's financial circumstances
and where the stress points were in
regard to their stability and we quickly
realized that the education part of the
mix with all due respect to a learning
institution that the education part of
the mix was sort of farther down the
list of where they were in trouble we
have 800,000 New York adults that don't
have bank accounts 800,000 we have a
million New Yorkers who qualify for the
Earned Income Tax Credit and they're
about 175 of them 175 thousand of them
that still don't know it and claim those
dollars we have people that are being
preyed upon all the time by debt
settlement companies that are saying
just give us 100 bucks and we'll fix
your life
we have people being harassed by debt
collectors often for debts they don't
know and so we started thinking about
the lives of consumers or New Yorkers in
the financial services marketplace and
thinking a little bit about who we were
at Consumer Affairs what we thought we
could bring to bear with city government
and fast-forward a little bit we created
something that we call the office of
financial empowerment within my agency
the office of financial empowerment
sought to approach this question of
helping people with their financial
circumstances and we identified four
very clear pillars that we were going to
be focusing our work on and trying to
make a difference the first of which was
sort of in our DNA already and that was
consumer protection of the 55 industries
that our department directly regulates
and there are we
indirectly regulate all industries but
directly regulate in license 55 we
license debt collectors if you're a debt
collector and you want to collect from a
New Yorker no matter where you are in
the world you need to get a license from
us you need to follow our rules you need
to answer to our mediators if you screw
up and we call the call you on the phone
and say you're pursuing a three thousand
dollar debt prove they owe it prove this
is the right person etc etc we've got 47
states and nine countries worth of
licensees in debt collection alone
looking to come after you we license
debt collectors we license used car
dealers we licensed Process Servers I
don't know how many of you know the role
that process servers play if the
creditor is going to come after you and
bring you to court for not paying a bill
they're gonna file some paperwork with
the court the only way you're gonna know
it is when a process server serves you
with those papers process servers are
not known for being all that great about
service and there's this wonderful
expression called sewer service anyone
ever heard of that expression sewer
service is a little you know entry into
my world sewer service is where a
process server will toss the papers in
the sewer and then swear to the court
that they gave you the papers and so you
never know that you have been sued by a
creditor you don't show up at court
obviously the creditor wins because it's
a default you're not there the bank the
judge seizes your bank accounts freezes
them destroys your credit rating and you
are in a world of trouble so process
servers are really a key a key player
unfortunately in this world of people
who get in trouble with their finances
employment agencies we regulate there
was a real constellation of our license
categories where we thought to ourselves
you know there really is a way to think
differently about not just here are the
rules that we want to make sure you
follow them but thinking a little bit
more proactively about how are these
impacting how are the practices of these
industries impacting on people who get
into trouble so consumer protection was
the obvious first pillar for us it's who
we are
but then the three other pillars were
safe access to banking services savings
and other asset building opportunities
and then the fourth was financial
education and counseling I want to zero
in on the fourth
Gouri for now but we've done a lot of
really exciting work in some of those
other categories we've got tax time
savings programs we have negotiated with
banks and credit unions in the city to
offer free bank accounts where you're
not going to get screwed by overdraft we
have really come up with some really
great ways to leverage the city and and
leverage the fact that we run so many
programs along with our sister agencies
but when it came to financial education
and counseling we said to ourselves as I
said before what's the unique value add
what can we do well I can tell you who
we weren't going to be we weren't going
to be the new kid on the block that came
out with the Bloomberg curriculum and
said we've decided that we're entering
this field we're big bad government
everybody's heard of Bloomberg he's
famous and rich this is what we think
everyone needs to know you know it's
it's not it's not who the mayor is it's
not who we are it certainly wouldn't
have been interesting and and you know
with all due respect to some of you who
have labored hard on websites including
my own staff who needs another website
instead what we said to ourselves was
well first and foremost let's figure out
what array of services are already
available in the city from nonprofit
providers and ask ourselves how can we
help them and so one of the things that
we were able to do is take this
incredibly powerful tool that at this
point we all take for granted but a few
years ago we didn't even have it which
is 3-1-1 right you remember the blue
pages and the yellow pin that in the
phone book if you needed help from the
government you had to thumb through
these blue pages and figure out well how
would this be
which department all of that 3-1-1 got
rid of all of that you all probably
don't even imagine or what it was so
many of you here you're so young
but I digress I'm about to turn 50 um so
so one of the things that we were able
to do is pull together all of the
existing providers in the nonprofit
world of financial free you know decent
at least financial education and
counseling services and put them into a
network and use 3-1-1 as the incredibly
simple universal way to connect the
public to whatever services were already
available now that dozen
seemed like all that big a deal but it
was huge because one of the problems
that our nonprofit friends were having
is they couldn't fill their seats they
would beg borrow and fundraise to get
the ability to try to help people and
you know many of you I'm sure know how
difficult that can be ting to raise
money and to keep that money going and
to bring on the right staff so that
you're offering those services and so
one of the things we want to do is to
make it as easy as possible for them to
be able to reach as many people as
possible
so now you can search online or call
3-1-1 and a hundred and seventy two
languages 24 hours a day and say things
like I'm looking for a budgeting class
in Russian is there one where would it
be I'm looking for debt relief services
where somebody speaks Bengali does it
exist you know the ability to make those
connections seemed important the second
thing we did is we turned this group of
providers into a community and to our
great surprise they weren't already so
was it it was we were able to start to
talk to them about best practices new
threats on the horizon we pull them
together every quarter and we're all
able to teach each other that's always
important the third thing we did is what
I'm really here to talk about which is
we created something which are now known
as financial empowerment centers so
here's what we knew if as government we
were going to step forward to the public
and say hey are you far are your
finances in trouble call 3-1-1
we need it to be able and this pressure
is really wonderful pressure we needed
to be able to do more than say I hope
you find what you need and in particular
what we knew and this is what you all
know is when somebody's in trouble a
class doesn't fix their life a website
doesn't change their world great
brochure is not going to tell them how
to make the specific decisions that they
have to make with the bills in front of
them and the court papers or whatever it
is if somebody's actually in trouble
they need to sit down with a
professional and get help I know you all
agree with that or you wouldn't be
spending all this money
fabulous program so we also knew in
pulling together this network that the
availability of one-on-one counseling
was almost non-existent there was one
really terrific provider that had raised
the money to have somebody every other
Friday for three hours that was really
the extent of where somebody could go if
they wanted to sit down with somebody
that they could trust who would sit down
and look at their papers and talk about
things like what's the crisis in front
of you are there benefits that you might
be missing you've got these court papers
let's unravel it you've got this credit
card bill for $1,000 that has somehow
mushroomed into 3,700 because of fines
and fees and all of that what are we
gonna do about that so from the
beginning of understanding the world of
what was out there we knew that there
that the key piece was missing and that
as government we just couldn't look
ourselves in the mirror and say that we
were somehow making the world a better
place by telling people to call 3-1-1
for the one thing that we really weren't
able to give them so then we had to ask
ourselves well alright it's a big city
there are a lot of people in financial
trouble if we're going to try to put
together quality one-on-one counseling
services as government we're going to
have to really ring a couple of bells
the first bell and the one that's most
relevant I think to you all is we have
to make sure that the quality of the
service being offered is high if you're
going to tell people hey Mayor Bloomberg
thinks that's a good idea for you to go
to this Center over here and sit down
and get advice about your finances can't
screw it up and when you're talking
about people's finances it's dangerous
because you really can screw it up and
you can get people in a lot of trouble
the second thing we needed to be able to
do is we needed to be able to offer
these services at scale and scale in New
York is you know scale so we couldn't
build a model that was so difficult to
replicate that we could only sort of pat
ourselves in the back
say we helped 40 people last week or
last month you know it's just it's not
enough
the need is too great and when you step
forward and say you're answering the
need you need to be able to answer it
the third thing is that we needed to be
able to have a consistency across the
system so we needed professional
delivery of these services we needed a
model that could be replicated at scale
and we needed to make sure that that
replication involved apples to apples
experiences and so we put together very
rigorous protocols what is a counseling
session what data are we tracking what
measurable outcomes are we expecting
from our contracted counseling partners
and where is that data so that we can
constantly be drawing upon it now
initially when we did this we raised
private money and this is the way if you
paid attention to some of this this is
the way that Mayor Bloomberg has really
done a lot of his more innovative work
in the city which is go raise some
private dollars and try it prove the
case and then sort of talk about whether
or not it's something appropriate for
the public to be paying for if you fast
forward from this creation of this
financial empowerment center model and
interestingly we created our first
financial empowerment center the very
first pilot was up in Brook in the Bronx
we worked with Phipps as our as our
partner and it was going well and it was
you know showing a lot of results and it
was exciting and we were you know
counting up the number of dollars
literally reduced when our councilors
were picking up the phone and calling
creditors and all of that and we were in
the beginning of evaluating it and it
was all exciting and then the economy
went to hell and so as I said we were
sort of in the right place at a terrible
time and the mayor turned to us and said
this is looking good people are in
trouble ramp it up and so for the next
couple of years
still with private dollars we quickly
went from one Center to I think
initially five and then they started
mushrooming fast-forward a couple of
years and here's what we've done in I
guess now is it three years issuing your
for we have had over 30,000 counseling
sessions for about 20,000 clients we
have helped our clients reduce their
debt one counselor at a time a couple
hundred dollars at a time by about ten
million dollars is that right
I know it's I I hear it's almost 10
million we have built savings with our
clients in the neighborhood of a million
dollars we have opened up I forget how
many bank accounts but there's a number
and you know as and a host of other
services our ability to say to the mayor
when you make this investment in high
quality counseling this is what you get
for it this is literally how people's
lives are better when they walk out of a
counseling session this is literally
what happens when they come back for a
second or a third counseling session and
the way their credit scores have changed
over time then you make a very powerful
case for a service that is worth its
weight and so now just about two years
ago when the mayor was struggling to cut
five billion dollars out of our public
budget he decided to publicly fund this
new service so financial empowerment
centers in New York City are now part of
the baseline public budget that might
not sound like a big deal to all of you
but it's huge it means that it has sort
of reached that knotch of this is what a
city ought to be offering it has reached
that notch of even when times are tough
and we're closing senior centers and
doing all these other really difficult
choices about how to spend public
dollars we are going to make sure that
people had access to high quality
professional counseling one quick side
note I have used the word professional a
lot I want to talk about that for a
second and I think that's relevant to
you all from the beginning it was very
important to us that what we were
building was a field of professional
counseling that it was something so far
from
well-meaning volunteers in a church
basement trying to help somebody deal
with their mail to people who had been
trained not just on personal finance
which is important and good for all of
us but trained on how to be a financial
counsellor trained on how to understand
the particular issues and challenges of
people with low incomes trained on
people's consumer rights in the
financial services marketplace trained
on the psychology of money and the role
that it plays in people's ability to
absorb help and and take it and so from
the beginning we said let's not just
make this an in-house training that
we're proud of
let's make this real let's make this a
path toward professionalism and so
initially we started working with the
City University of New York who helped
us develop the initial curriculum and
offered the class which is now a three
credit class and then came the most
magic moment for us which is when
Columbia agreed to offer it in your
program both as a core course and as a
field placement it's completely
thrilling for us and it's thrilling for
us not just because you all are great
and the school is great and the name is
great and all of that but because it
represents this vision for what society
ought to expect and honor in this
critical service of counseling people
about their finances and as we fast
forward from that first financial
empowerment Center in the Bronx to a
citywide network of now publicly funded
financial empowerment centers at the
same time this professional one-on-one
municipal designated counseling model is
starting to be replicated across the
country cities across the country are
raising money to offer our model of
service universities and colleges are
using this curriculum and variations of
this curriculum
to trained counselors in credit-bearing
courses and field placement hopefully
soon opportunities elsewhere with the
idea that this is something government
ought to do this is something unique
that government can do for its residents
and that this service is so important
that it ought to be part of a
professional career path for people who
care about the lives of people in front
of them something else has happened in
the evolution of this public service and
that is that we discovered that in
addition to the impact of the work
itself in addition to being able to
quantify how much debt is reduced how
many bank accounts are opened how credit
scores are shifting etc etc we also
started partnering with some of our
sister agencies in their programs and
inserting some of the work that we were
doing across the spectrum of our
financial empowerment work for example I
don't know how many of you remember a
few years back the mayor did a program
called the conditional cash transfer
program we was trying to leverage
anti-poverty fighting behaved
anti-poverty behaviors by literally
paying people every two months if they
did X Y or Z it was a model that he
borrowed from Mexico's controversial but
interesting and it's certainly a big
effort one of the things that we knew is
that these people who are going to be
part of this study and I think there
were 5,000 of them or 3,000 and there's
something like that we knew that a huge
portion of them we're gonna be unbanked
and we thought well you're measuring the
impact of money you're gonna hand them a
check and they're gonna take it to a
check casher what's wrong with this
picture and so it was one of our early
efforts of where we said well I know
what I'm gonna do I'm going to I'm gonna
use the mayor's name as well as much as
I can and I'll flash my badge or
whatever I have to do and I'm gonna see
how many banks and credit unions I can
get to offer a safe account and I'm
gonna insert bank account opening into
the registration process for this other
program and sure enough we had a
population of 47% of that population was
unbanked when they showed up because
they wanted to be part of that program
and by the end of the registration
period only 3% weren't
everyone said yes they got this bank
account it wasn't gonna screw them the
city had told them it was safe we
actually had several providers they
could pick whichever one they want it
was the NYC safe account I think is what
we called it her opportunity account or
something and we realized that this work
it's great that we got more people
banked but what was really exciting is
we had actually helped this host program
better achieve some of its outcomes fast
forward that light bulb now several
years and we have a series of efforts
that we refer to as the super vitamin
effect so that's that you probably have
that in front of you it's we have our
first three reports that we put together
in a compendium and we started
recognizing and this is the thing that
you all know and I think this is the
magic of why our Columbia partnership
has always made so much sense when
you're dealing with people because
they're at risk of losing their home
when you're dealing with people because
they're having trouble escaping domestic
violence when you're dealing with
prisoner re-entry aging out of foster
care etc etc etc etc financial
instability is a powerful force flowing
through those clients lives they're not
what you're necessarily trained to deal
with they're not necessarily what your
resource to deal with but if you want to
make sure that somebody who you spend
all this time and effort and money and a
workforce development program if you
want to make sure that they keep showing
up for their job then you're going to
want to make sure they've got a little
reserve of savings so that if they have
to hire a new babysitter or if their car
breaks down or whatever it is they can
keep showing up to this job that you
just worked on domestic violence the
first or second depending on which study
you take a look at greatest reason P
women go back seven times on average is
because of their finances and if you're
not able to figure out how to address
their finances you're not really going
to get to one of the core factors in
getting these people help so this idea
of this super vitamin effect that our
work was great in and of itself for what
it was supposed to be but that it was
this really interestingly useful tool
for other public programs the sort of
the class
social and human service programs that
were out there really motivated us to
start thinking about and piloting and
studying how that worked where it worked
how you set it up so that it could flow
as part of the delivery stream of those
services and if this interests you I
hope it does you know you could thumb
through this report look at the
executive summary of the first one it'll
give you a little bit more of a flavor
of this and that's been very exciting
for us it's been very exciting for the
asset building world which is always
trying to figure out how to reach a
broader audience but more and more it's
been very exciting to our fellow
commissioners who are now knocking on
our door saying I can't get these people
at a shelter can you help me I you know
where are my counselors are frustrated
because we don't know how to tell these
people what to do about the fact that
their abuser stole their financial
identity and they can't open a bank
account and so that's been very exciting
I mentioned earlier that we were doing
national replications of this work we
created a couple of national iterations
of who we are we created a coalition of
other mayors that are doing this work
and that's called the cities for
financial empowerment coalition about a
year ago we created a non-profit arm to
help other cities do this as well as a
funder and that's called the cities for
financial empowerment fund and recently
the CFE fund announced this very large
grant for cities and mayor's who wanted
to open up these financial empowerment
center models and we said to them as
part of this grant don't just raise your
hand and say you want money so that you
can sort of have counseling out there
here's what you have to do for the money
you have to find a local educational
provider who's going to offer this
professional training and an ongoing
basis in credit during classes and you
have to identify these different
integration opportunities of where
you're going to make sure that these
services are more than just lovely
standalone services but start to become
the fabric of the array of solutions
that you're offering in your Human
Services world as well we had 48 cities
apply for that experience which is very
exciting
ultimately we were only able to fund
five of them but in each of these five
cities we will be experimenting with
different versions of this kind of super
vitamin integration I recently gave a
lecture in st. Louis with Professor
Sheridan probably a lot of you know of
his working sagen he was he didn't even
call me and one of the things that
Professor Sharad and said which I
thought was so great is he said you know
social work actually we used to be the
ones that cared about people's finances
and he told this wonderful story I don't
know if he talked about filling bathtubs
with coal and you know sort of creating
cooperatives with clients to try to help
share on coal expenses at any rate the
social work handshake is a natural and
it's it's just a very exciting it's a
very exciting way for us to take this
vision that we have and that we've been
exploring and starting to replicate and
really underscore the idea that this is
what we ought to be doing for people who
are in trouble that we can do it and
that we can do it at large scale so I'm
really excited about your interest
possibly in pursuing that experience
through your program and in learning
more about the way that cities like New
York are trying to do it I want to stop
for a minute before I take any questions
or comments and ask Monica Copeland
who's going to be teaching the next
course I believe here to talk a little
bit about the class in what is
shamelessly a pitch
hi everybody I just want to thank thank
you all for coming and taking this time
to learn about this great work that
we're doing it's it's groundbreaking
work on a local level to do what in New
York is amazing but then to also see the
work being spread nationally is also
really wonderful we are teaching a
course the office of financial
empowerment has been granted an
opportunity to for the second time to
teach a spring class and so it's
actually in session now it takes place
from 2:00 to 3:50 p.m. on Wednesdays in
room 11 o 9 so I'm letting you know so
that in case you're interested in
potentially coming to sit in this week's
session if you have half time you're
welcome to join us
and then if you want to sign up and
register please do so before drop at so
this course is called personal financial
management and financial counseling
skills and so you'll be learning content
that you would from a practical sense
about your personal finances whether
it's credit banking bankruptcy insurance
benefits all of those practical matters
but then you're also going to learn how
to potentially integrate this in future
settings because we think this
information has as commissioner mints
really eloquently explained it fits in
so many of the sectors that you're
already in you could be clinical you
could be direct practice you could be
serving in an agency PP practice FCA
policy there's room for this content and
room to share it with your clients just
as an example when I was at Columbia in
2004 in 2002 2006 my field one of my
field placements was at pathways to
housing and so what I really liked about
that placement what was so fascinating
was that they believed in the housing
first model and so that that's just one
example of a strategy to deal with
homelessness and so they believed you
know we know that these clients have a
lot of issues whether it's their mental
illness they're homeless and you know
just a serious substance abuse issues
but the housing first concept was that
let's place them in housing first and
then address some of these issues
and so I used that sort of an analogy to
some of this financial Social Work
information because sometimes the client
can't concentrate on a lot of these
other issues that you're you know you
might be seeing them about you know a
therapy session family issues and ask an
at-risk youth but there can't
concentrate because of the money
stressors and then as social workers
we'd like you to be able to provide
quality of referrals because even if you
can't do it yourself at least you'll
know what the city has to offer and
where you can direct them that they
won't be preyed upon further so anyway
you can tell I'm very excited about the
class I hope you'll consider if you if
you do want to just check it out it's
from 2:00 to 350 on Wednesdays room 11
or 9:00 and then the second pitch I just
want to put forth is um we'll also be at
the field placement Fair so on Monday
February 4th will be there from 2:30 to
4:30 and learner Hall and we'll be
offering two field placements at the
Department of Consumer Affairs office of
financial empowerment next school year
for SCA students but this past year we
had almost one of each policy and a gtp
and SCA and so we have found that it's
been very helpful to have that have
those students and they're here today if
you want to talk to them but I just
wanted to say I'll be at the field
placement fair if your first year and
you weren't considering and that's of
interest the class is a prerequisite so
we hope that you take the class first
but if you're just curious and want to
know more
we're happy to answer those questions
and then lastly if you're a second year
and you just want to know about career
opportunities in this field I'd be happy
to talk to you about that as well
because it's there's a lot of options
and a lot of different directions you
can take it so alright um thank you so
much and we'll take questions are there
any questions or or comments yeah
if you were like let's say approached by
a large bank who wanted to become
involved in this process in addition to
providing bank accounts what would you
suggest to them and how to get involved
can you work for
well banks have actually been very
constructive partners for us I mentioned
that our early financial empowerment
center model was privately funded we had
banking funders in the early days when I
went to negotiate the bank accounts that
I talked about we've now done that in
several different contexts here's how I
do it what I have done is I have
literally reached out to every bank and
credit union serving the New York
marketplace and I tell them what I want
I tell them what the program is that I'm
going to be using it for who the
population is that they could get and
basically what I do is I offer up
government as a broker I say I'm going
to have this population they're going to
need bank accounts I want them to have
bank accounts this is the kind of bank
account that I need and any and all of
you that are willing to offer us that
account can be on our list of folks that
we're trying to hook up what I don't do
and you'll notice what I don't do is I
don't say to people oh you need a bank
account you should go get one right you
all know enough about behavioral
economics that's not going to happen I
don't say to people oh my sponsor is X
Bank you should go check out what they
have because the truth is X Bank
probably has some crappy accounts and I
don't want to put people in harm's way
so we are very aggressive with our
banking partners about what we need but
we are offering them something
significant which is government
brokering of customers and so that model
is also model that we started
replicating nationally we started a
movement called the Bangkok movement
which you may have heard of that is now
all over the country and tries to use
different approaches to connecting banks
and safe ways to people that we need so
that that's the way I work with banks is
I'll take their money and I'll take
their clinic counts
I think their account representatives a
registration to help open up those
accounts does that answer your question
banks have been great I mean they you
know I mean there are some that aren't
you know that have multiple voices and
some of them have some lousy accounts
and you know banks aren't always all
that popular and part of what I offered
in our propria say looks people don't
always trust banks
you know the reason 800,000 adults don't
have bank accounts it's not because
they're dumb and they've never heard of
banks it's because they don't trust
banks so let's put together an account
that that people can trust let me put my
in pramada on it of the city as account
that it's you know they're not gonna
regret that one account that I mentioned
that first time we did it in that
opportunity program two years later like
90 some percent of the account holders
still had the account that account
hadn't been closed down because of
overdraft fees it hadn't gotten messed
up it had been simple and
straightforward and people didn't regret
it so so that's that's our approach to
working with banks it's really important
you can't help people in the financial
services marketplace by sheltering them
from the marketplace you have to show
them the right way to navigate it it's a
good question yes thank you um I think
the marriage of Social Work and
financial literacy makes this makes
complete sense
I was wondering have you have you
partnered at all with Department of
Education I feel like financial literacy
within a younger cohort I mean we were
chatting in terms of yeah you know they
prey on college students for example so
I've been getting people before
graduation yeah and I was just curious
about gender differences it was there
when you first rolled this out you
talked about saving the ten million
dollar savings was I was just curious if
it was disproportionately well my answer
the latter question first we do know a
lot about the demographics of our of our
clients at the financial empowerment
centers they are predominantly women
probably not surprising right as the
father of two daughters and you know
they are predominantly women and we
could get you you know might be
interested in more but they're
predominantly women they are
predominantly single mothers
and so they're out there getting the
help that they need right and your first
question about the Department of
Education it's a question I get a lot
it's a great idea you know if we run for
a fourth term I'll take it on just
kidding we're done the it's hard you
know the department you know I talk I
know the Chancellor very well it's you
know they have 1.1 million students they
have a huge list of things they have to
master and do and so cracking that nut
has been a little bit more difficult
systematically there's a lot going on
here and there my interest has been as
you probably could tell in systems and
so I've really been trying to figure out
what the right approach to that is and
and New York is harder now my I
mentioned this coalition that we started
this national coalition our co-chair
city of San Francisco and San Francisco
did something very interesting they have
much much smaller cohorts I'm jealous
but it made sense and they created
something called the kindergarten to
college account and they are literally
opening up bank accounts with depending
on your income level fifty or hundred
dollars for every single kid in
kindergarten in the public school system
so there are and you'll you'll find this
interesting and as a former teacher said
oh I using the fact that people have
these accounts as a way to integrate
into early versions of curriculum before
it was a little awkward sometimes to
talk a little bit about money and bank
accounts when you didn't think that most
of the kids here yeah of course right
yeah there's me
yeah it's certainly you know and the end
and I would just add the notion that I
talked a little bit about before with my
consumer protection hat on which is just
as you mentioned college students I mean
these are just these are just preyed
upon
that's right yeah right we did a we did
a large campaign recently in fact I will
say this is I feel like I could take
every other campaign we've done over the
last 11 years and it still wouldn't add
up to the impact of this one campaign
about proprietary colleges and schools
and student loans what was the name of
the campaign know before you enroll
Thank You Fran and the the impact of
this I mean for months and months and
months I had folks asked me to come on
radio stations and TV shows I mean
everyone wants to talk about this
because student loans are just not that
you all have student loans I'm sure you
all got full assistance but there you go
other questions yeah actually I wanted
to also acknowledge fran freedman for
bringing the project to us and leashing
who has been working from the ground up
Monica of course in yourself take full
credit for them they're they're just
amazing and wonderful and I was
skeptical and all but I'm totally on
board now so there are three things that
I just want to mention number one we can
probably help you with the schools
because I just came back from a very
exciting meeting with TC so we can talk
about that later the other thing is that
we can probably also help you reach a
national audience if you're interested
in certification programs we have a
means by which we could do that if
people want the Colombian promoter let's
talk the third thing is if you want to
do any work internationally and we also
have that as a possibility you're my new
favorite person that's great
that's apps absolutely that's perfect
thank you other questions yes
I think that I think that where our
sweet spot tends to be in people with
incomes you know there are and there are
services that are really geared purely
toward benefits enrollment and that sort
of thing but I think we tend to be at
our best in the way that you're
currently making your referrals where
we're able to sort of help people make
the most of the incomes that are coming
in
that's the segment that we're trying to
capture primarily I think that makes the
most sense now that having been said
when you have people in trouble if you
have people being harassed for a debt
they don't owe for example they should
be calling three one one and let one of
our mediators you know let us let the
public services let those other public
services you know be part of the picture
as well okay other questions yes
it's a great question you know we Fran
always has her social worker hat on
under her Deputy Commissioner hat and
you know when we did we did a lot of
public advertising you know we buy we
own the subways these days you know in
terms of ads and just as one example and
we thought a lot about how we how we
captured this unfortunately almost
universal sense of frustration with
finances in the sense that they couldn't
there was no light at the end of the
tunnel or you know whatever the metaphor
would be and I think we had actually a
pretty good early campaign that spoke to
lower-middle-class not necessarily just
lower lower income and I don't mean to
make too much out of like which stock
models you use for an ad but I think we
did pretty quickly tap into and remember
also this is when the economy was really
going to hell and so our problem wasn't
so much people with lower incomes who
were a little bit more predisposed to
knowing that there's help available and
where is it and sometimes actually quite
adept at finding that help but we were
starting to think a little bit about
people in the lower middle class who
were now finding themselves in trouble
and who are definitely not used to
thinking that government service free
opportunities you know something they
could do so that was part of it a
marketing mark one of the unique powers
of government is our bullhorn so we were
able to produce all sorts of marketing
opportunities and figure out ways to get
free you know earned what do they call
it earned press whatever earned PR
whatever it is free press you know get
on TV shows and get on radio shows and
start to announce some of the results in
that sort of thing we did a wonderful
early experiment with the Daily News
where for a week we had this call center
I forget what we called it I forget what
we call it but what you know and every
day there were articles in in the Daily
News that were sort of saying a bit look
we took like four hundred calls today
here's an average call and you know all
the elected officials show up and they
take a call so they can get the picture
you know you know and really just tried
to continue to mainstream it and to have
in the way that the mayor talked about
it when I could get it onto his bullhorn
you know to talk about just the sort of
again the universality of the fact that
this stuff gets complicated and you need
help when it gets complicated and and
then the final thing I'd say to answer
your question is and this is again with
my consumer protection chops which is
just that people knew that they were
being preyed upon they knew they needed
help they were really you know there was
no question that everyone was telling
them that they had the magic solution
for only $120 and so I think there
really was a lot of pent up relief and
it didn't take long before our
counseling sessions were three weeks
booked out which is pretty darn exciting
yeah in thinking in thinking about the
quality of service you're looking to
provide in the one-on-one counseling
sessions I'm thinking I'm wondering what
the experience has been in working with
low income folks that we're long-term
financial planning has not exactly been
something that's been a sort of a
something available to them necessarily
and so in thinking about setting up bank
accounts introducing the idea of long
term planning for folks where that's not
that hasn't really been the case just
want to give you an example
Monica Copeland mentioned pathways to
housing I oversee a family support
program for a housing first model as
well and we recently had a number of the
tenants living in our buildings who got
their first apartment they were really
excited looking really positively
towards the future and then the holidays
hit and they wanted to buy their kids
really nice gifts and give them a great
Christmas yeah so what did that do put a
bunch of them into rent arrears they're
now in debt so I'm just wondering what
the experience has been in trying to
introduce a new way of looking at money
when so on it hasn't been the case
it's a great question so I want to
answer it in two ways the first is I
mentioned that one of the other pillars
of our work was on building savings and
we from the beginning had to counter the
myth that people with low incomes even
people with high debts wouldn't and
couldn't save and so we developed this
really interesting program which is is
called save my see it's now also being
nationally replicated through the white
house it's called save USA where people
were able to segregate part of their
AITC returns their earned income tax
credit returns right on the split tax
form and if they saved it for a year we
were matching their money and we had
amazing having amazing results so one of
the things that I would say is that when
you engage people in the right way with
the right products with the right
behavioral economic cues people want to
think about their futures even when
their presence our stress stressed the
second thing and more directly answering
your question is that people don't
almost never come into a financial
empowerment center and say hey I'd like
to think about the future hey I'd like
to build some savings in a college
account it's not usually why people come
to us usually people come to us because
they're in trouble but the beauty of I
think the way this has worked is we
don't just say to them oh you're having
your hearing from this debt collector
let's sit down and let's look at this
bill and let's call the debt collector
and hey that's great what we do is we
say let's start with the financial
health assessment let's figure out the
whole mix what do you have coming in
what do you have going out what's going
on so that you have the seeds to be able
to say okay now let's take a look at
this one issue with the debt collector
let's show you how to fix it what else
can we fix you mentioned that you're
also behind on this payment let's take a
look at it are there any fees that are
piling up why don't we give them a call
and put you on a new payment plan and so
once you start to show somebody and this
is why I was talking a little bit before
about tangible help once you start to
show them that there is tangible help
then suddenly the floodgates open in so
many of cases and people start to
realize it's worth their while to
to take on some of those other pieces
and our counselors who are very well
trained know that part of what you're
trying to do at the same time is build
the the seeds of you know putting
together some savings putting together a
bank account whatever the right next
steps are for those clients who are
while not presenting with that goal who
tend to often leave with that goal so so
I think that's how you do it you stare
them with something helpful and then you
sucker-punch them with something
long-term helpful that's not the
expression we use our training materials
bait-and-switch sucker-punching it's
yeah I'm from the New York Asian Women's
Center and we're one of the domestic
violence programs that our counselors
are receiving the financial empowerment
counseling training that's great yeah
it's very encouraging but we're very
early on in kind of incorporating this
type of work into the services that we
regularly regularly provide so I was
just wondering where whether there have
been certain settings or certain
populations where you're seeing this
super vitamin affect particularly
effective I'll read my report it's a
great question in fact we wrote a whole
report about it you know seriously you
know that we have we have really we have
made some real mistakes that have been
very constructive where we have tried to
insert the services at the wrong moments
you want to get people when they're in
crisis but only at certain points of
when they're in crisis and then only in
certain crises and you want to find the
right kinds of partners you know the
partnership that you mentioned is one
that frankly took us a little bit of
time to get going some marriages are a
little harder to broker that one's going
great now we're very excited about it
so so when you take a look at that I
think it's our very first report where
we sort of lay out our quick lessons and
it's about finding the right partnership
it's about finding the intersections of
sectors that that get that their stress
points are impacted by the financial
stress at the clients that they're not
otherwise already dealing with
and you know some of our more successful
efforts to date have been with people in
the homeless services arena where people
are getting renters assistance and other
ways to try to connect them in their
homes and not falling into shelters but
we're having an increasing series of
good experiences and I think you'll like
the report I hope I thinks I hope that
experience is going well if you're
having it it is it's a big one it's the
one I talk about a lot actually okay yes
thank you for this this very
enlightening presentation I work with a
faculty member here Fred so Amala he's a
he's a professor and a researcher and
he's been doing Financial Inclusion
research for the past ten years in
developing countries primarily
sub-saharan Africa so it's just really
interesting to listen to the to the
us-based
trajectory of how this is unfolded
because you've pointed to many
similarities that are taking place in
Africa as well for example the distrust
of banks the myth that poor people don't
have any money to say don't want to save
but what we found in the research is
that low-income people save a save a
higher proportion of their income
compared to middle income people so
that's very interesting my question to
you is really exciting yes my question
is we do research and as you mentioned
the the difficulty in working with banks
we don't really have an incentive for
the banks other than reminding them of
their corporate social responsibility so
I'm wondering you know like what
strategies you might have in working
with banks and how how do we kind of
present a long-term business case I mean
this is probably a longer session no I
it's a great I have an answer for you
when one of the our first research
studies was on the marketplace of the
unbanked and we did something beyond the
expected we didn't just go out there and
count how many people were unbanked and
we didn't just go out there and whine
about the fact that there were some poor
neighborhoods that didn't have
brick-and-mortar banking institutions we
looked also at the demand side we took a
look at what
unbanked were doing for their financial
needs we started quantifying like I
think this was several years ago I think
in the community we studied in the Bronx
Mott Haven no Rose sorry in Melrose I
think we quantified that there were 19
million dollars being spent to check
cashers and so part of what I did you
want to talk about a marketplace I
literally went to boardrooms of banks
and said don't you want this 19 million
I want you to have it if you're offering
a safe account I don't want to waste it
now maybe not 19 million maybe with us
maybe it'll just be 14 million but you
know so part of it is I think our
strategy was about very much a
marketplace based strategy which is this
money is being spent
people are cashing their checks people
are sending money orders they're sending
wire transfers they're engaged in the
financial services marketplace they're
just engaged in the fee based fringe
version of these services and we'd like
you to bring them in that's one approach
the second approach I mentioned a little
earlier when I talked a little bit about
the role that government can play in
brokering you know one of our accounts
we were pushing out this is our Summer
Youth Employment Program we were pushing
out 30 million dollars to 50,000 young
adults that's a lot of money and I was
shameless about it
you know we've all gotten to know each
other well enough you're probably not
surprised I was shameless about it I
went to the banks and said don't you
want this don't you want these clients
well this is the price to entry you know
you want me to sell your account it's
got to be this account it's got to have
these terms I'm gonna sell as many of
them as each of you is willing to offer
and you're welcome
now it's served my purposes as well but
serve theirs just fine and banks are
really interested in that we're
currently we're about to release I don't
think we've released it yet a really
interesting study that we've done around
the financial service needs of three
different ethnic communities that was
funded by the banks the banks want to
know more about you know for their own
purposes for their social goodwill
purposes but but there are profit-making
institutions they want to know how to
capture these clients
and I'd rather have them capture them
with save products which are
increasingly safe thanks to the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau and your
president but I think that's how you do
it I think a market-based strategy is
very smart and certainly the DNA of the
Bloomberg administration last question
and then you have to get out I wanted
just to add a footnote that professors
say ramallah whose work she's talking
about was Michael Shraddha is doctoral
student oh is that right
oh great great he's he's wonderful
it all comes around we all now know but
well on behalf of everyone here thank
you so much this was absolutely an
enlightening and delightful and we
really enjoyed it thank you very much